Kelly is in Utah hi Kelly welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi they thank you for
taking my call
sure what's up my question is my husband
and I are starting the baby steps and we
are really wanting to get design and
henceforth keep your tired of being sick
and tired and then my question is my
husband works and I'm a stay-at-home mom
and so I wanted to bring in some more
income obviously to help pay out these
debts fasters do you have any
recommendations for say a month to you
know look for what to look for in
different companies when trying to you
know get hired on with them I generally
find some kind of a self-employed idea
to be preferable in that situation
you've got a lot more flexibility and
you usually make a lot more money per
hour what did you do before you were a
stay-at-home mom actually was a realtor
okay so you know the real estate
business yes excellent you saw have your
license active and if they're not there
right now just because it was it was
getting too hard with a little wonder
system I got you
well if you are reactivated it and found
a high producing realtor someone who is
selling a bazillion houses that needed a
some strong administrative help you
might be able to do a lot of processing
of different pieces of their paperwork
so to speak or web entries and that kind
of thing from home at your pace meaning
the realtor might dump or the real
estate agent might dump several files on
you sometime during the day and then
when your child's taking a nap then you
can sit down there and do the file entry
or or do the letters to clients or
follow-ups or whatever you could do a
lot of stuff you'd be a lot more
valuable doing that than you would some
multi level thing or than you would some
you know minimum wage type you know
flipping a burger somewhere or something
part-time right okay and so just what
I'm saying my friend Dan Miller who does
career coaching he says that anytime
you're going to try to make some money
it the easiest way to make some money is
to gather a bouquet of flowers from
those that are within reach and that
usually
means your existing skill sets and
experiences are probably your fastest
way to make some money rather than
trying to reinvent the wheel right okay
my friend rabbi lapin says that when
Jewish people think they need some money
that the Jewish culture teaches them to
not say oh where can I find a job it
teaches them to say to themselves who
can I find to serve mm-hmm and if you
find somebody to serve they'll give you
certificates of appreciation with
presidents faces on them that's what I
need assistance that's what I would look
for that's exactly what I would look hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind